I think you want to stay out of a
symmetric battle for who can slop
harder. If there's a competitor and
they're spamming a lot and you're like,
"Well, our only solution is to spam
harder." And you're just in an arms race
of who can create the most garbage to
make the graph go up.
>> I I think don't do it. I think you have
to find a way to stay out of trying to
produce the most lowquality crap.
>> This is Dalton plus Michael. Today we're
going to talk about slop versus crap.
Maybe another way to describe this is
like what does it mean to have good
taste? Why don't we kick this off? You
and I were talking about claude code.
You've maybe gone down the smallest of
rabbit holes. How is cloud code changing
how you think about slop versus craft?
>> Sure. So I think for context, I've been
doing a fair amount of programming over
the past uh nine months. Mh.
>> Um, like I was messing with cursor and
wind surf a while ago and it was cool
and
>> you know I've been having fun with it
and then of course cloud code came out
probably a while ago but it it really
took off mimemetically
>> Q4 of last year and definitely over like
Christmas break is when everyone
>> went nuts with it. And what I would say
is
>> it's really fun.
>> It's like a video game and you like type
stuff in and it just feels powerful like
you watch the screen fly by. It's like
programming with the best programmer
you've ever met who's like really nice
and really fast and it's so energizing
to watch the code fly by on the on the
screen and um see all the tokens it's
burning and just like you know it's it's
super cool. So I would recommend it.
Yes. And this is not yet another you
know VC podcast talking about how great
Claude Code is because here's where I'm
going with this. It is great. No, it is
great. But I easily could imagine a
younger version of myself
>> not really sleeping or taking care of
myself and then being convinced that all
of this junk that I was making with
cloud code was really good.
>> Yeah.
>> It reminds me of like I remember setting
up Linux when uh when I was super young
>> and I used this version of Linux called
Gen 2. Okay.
>> Where you would compile the whole thing
from scratch. And so when you were
setting up Linux, it would just be like
stuff would be flying by on the terminal
and I felt like a really elite guy that
I was like handcompiling my own Linux
kernel.
>> Yes.
>> And in retrospect that was like not
>> maybe I should be telling a story, but
like it felt really cool
>> to compile your own Linux kernel when in
practice I
>> literally nothing beneficial happened
for that. Okay. And so where I'm going
with this is there's such a temptation
that even I felt
>> Yeah.
>> using these super powerful tools to
basically make slop.
>> Yeah.
>> So let's define slop. Like I'd like to
hear your definition like what what
>> Yeah. What do we mean by slop here?
>> Very simply in my mind slop is products
that don't actually help the user. They
can seem great in your mind. They can
great when you're demoing. They can seem
great when you're raising money. But
when we put it in front of the intended
user, we do not see the user getting
their problem solved and then being
happy. It's like, oh, it's just missing
one thing.
That's a that's it's the it's the
feature treadmill where you're like, oh,
it's bad, but just let me add 10 more
features.
Like, and again, it's so tempting. The
tools are so good. You can just keep
adding features to something that's kind
of crappy
>> and have a very large surface area very
fast.
>> Have a lot of crap.
>> Yeah. So that's kind of what I think
about with with slop. What do you think
when when you see slop?
>> By definition, this is subjective. And
so one person like you could say
anything slop and people can debate it
and that sounds very tedious. I think
the best definition is that in your own
objective mind,
>> you know, it's not that good.
like
>> like especially after you've like you
know taken a break and taken a walk or
gotten some sleep and then you really
look at what you're doing with fresh
eyes or people that you trust and you're
like actually this isn't that good
>> because in the in the in the Linux
example I gave come on like the hand
compiled Linux kernel was not actually
better than the one I downloaded from
Red Hat.
>> It's the same thing. And so I think you
have to have this like objective
perspective about if something is
actually good. Basically, you can't
practice self-deception. That's what I'm
trying to say. Slop is where you're sort
of actively selfdeceiving. Yes.
>> That your thing is good when you kind of
know it's not that good.
>> You know, as an aside, whenever I work
with a company and they say like, "Oh,
our competitor gets funded or newcome
gets funded." And they're super afraid.
The first thing I do is just like, "Have
you used the product?" Yeah.
>> Have you used it? Like you can't even
really determine whether something is
good or bad by not using it. Like if
you're taking all of the clues but you
don't try it, you're not getting any
signal.
>> Yep.
>> So we have some examples of slop um
which are fun. Um first one, web 2.0.
>> Yeah. SEO spam. Okay. So the real
insight when Google was taking off is
that if you could rank number one in
Google for something on
>> you like would make so much money.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. If you if you could like spam
your way for your e-commerce site to be
the number one Google search result, you
would Yeah. You'd make tons and tons of
money. So, guess what happened?
>> Or content and you put a little Google
ad on it,
>> right? Yeah.
>> So, guess what happened is a lot of
people built slop farms.
>> Yes.
>> To game Google so that they can end up
at the top of search results and make
money in various ways.
>> And they had very nice early graphs.
>> Yeah. They made a lot of money. I'm not
going to I'm not going to name any of
the names of these companies. You can
ask Chad GBT about this.
>> A lot of money. Not a lot of money
relative to successful companies. A lot
of money relative to
>> It looked like it was working.
>> Yes. It looked like it was working.
>> So they were spamming the hell out of
Google. Yes.
>> And some raised like VC money for this.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Um many I might argue.
>> Ultimately none of those are going
concerns anymore. Like it was like a a
brief moment in history where you could
spam Google and make lots of money and
then you were done. Uh this this is
something I've been calling it with PB.
He calls them turkey startups. You ever
seen the graph of the life of a turkey
>> where it's like getting better and
better and better and then one day it's
over.
>> That's a turkey startup. It's a turkey
graph. Oh man. You know, you know what
I'm talking about.
>> Yes. It's a little brutal.
>> It's like where you're like, "Oh, you
know, my startup's going great and then
it's just like over.
>> Google changed algorithm."
>> Yes. So, an SEO slop company is the
definition of a of a turkey startup. For
me, when I think back to mobile
consumer, there were so many products
where when you would dig deep, someone
would subscribe to them for a year and
their activity would end after 30 days.
And like the business model was like,
okay, like I love this business model. I
was like, all right, we're going to
acquire the user for this much. If we
get them to buy the annual subscription,
we we have one year LTV. That's pretty
good. And if we get them to like somehow
forget and subscribe for two years,
well, I mean that's silly. And then we
just run that play across 100 million
users. Yep. And all the graphs look
great. And remember like the early app
store was a lot of slop. It'd be like I
>> was lightsaber.
>> It was just like
>> crap. And people made money in the short
term. But again, none of those became
durable businesses because it was it was
slop. And Apple didn't want slop in the
app store either. Like no one was that
excited about this stuff. It was
effectively a scam.
>> It it was a scam and and there were
users understand when things are scam.
So you get like a negative word of mouth
and then you know you but to your point
like the SEO thing you look in the first
10% of the race you look like you're
winning.
>> Y
>> and it's like that's why it's like so
interesting because it's like man it's
so desirable to look like you're winning
in the first 10% of the race. You can
sometimes just forget that you have 90%
of the race to run. I just thinking
about this um out loud. It's almost like
the same
shills that are selling courses were
into all this stuff. Like like basically
on the the dark corners of YouTube of
like get rich quick.
>> They love this stuff. Like everything we
just mentioned,
>> there were totally people that were
like, "This is the secret to wealth."
And it was some version of like whatever
the latest scam was. Yes.
>> To like fool people.
>> Get in early and get out with money
before
>> Well, they made money selling courses.
So again, that's the irony is selling
>> selling content to explain to people how
to make slop
>> is probably a better business than
making slop. So
>> So then crypto happened which was slop
free, right?
>> I mean I think that the the thing with
that is it was so intoxicating in the
same way. Again I you know to speak to
myself when I first learned about you
know Bitcoin I thought it was super
cool. I remember telling you about it.
It was hard to think about anything else
for a little while. This was like in
2013 and 2014 because it seems so
revolutionary.
>> Yes.
>> Again, it reminds me of the feeling that
I've had messing with a lot of the vibe
coding tools like cloud code is just
feeling like I'm seeing the future and
feeling almost like a euphoria about it
and an excitement.
>> Yes. And because I've been through
multiple cycles before, current Dalton,
I was like, "Yeah, haha." Um, chill,
dude. That Yeah. Yeah. Um, and that and
that's kind of where I ended up with the
crypto stuff, too, which is to realize
there was an incentive
>> to do lowquality stuff with crypto like
ICOs or or you know, there there's a lot
of things like that. And ultimately, you
know, Enduring Value was not created in
as many of those as was created by
Coinbase and and what have you. I think
the the moment that crypto really kind
of jumped the shark for me. I remember I
was working with the company in the
batch who made something like a Discord
plugin or something and it was an
interesting seed that something could
have grown from.
>> Yeah.
>> And then they were
the the plan was to ICO
and monetize it and be done. dump on
retail.
>> And I was like I was like,
"You you guys have something like you
might be able to make something." And
they're like,
>> "What are you talking about?" Like
that's the game.
>> That's not the game we're playing.
>> Yeah.
>> And I was just like, "Oh, come." And and
again, to put a fine point on this, I
still think there's like really cool
things that are going to be built with
crypto,
>> obviously. But backwards facing
objectively, a lot of the startups were
the equivalent of like the crappy
Facebook apps or the crappy iPhone apps
or the SEO sites where they kind of got
some activity, maybe they made some
money and then there's it's a turkey.
Like there's nothing left.
>> Well, I think that's that's the
interesting thing is that like maybe the
difference between when we started and
now is the venture world has gotten so
much bigger and there's so much more
money. Yeah. Whereas I feel like a lot
of the things that were like this back
in the day had to bootstrap.
>> Yeah.
>> Whereas like some of the things like
this now, a lot of schlop can raise
funding.
>> Yep.
>> And so like that confuses people like
well how can it be schlop if it's
raising around right? Like
>> well this is where it goes back to the
thing I said earlier which is you have
to have your own good judgment.
>> Yeah.
>> And just because like if you're looking
around you're like everyone else is
scamming maybe I should scam too.
That's not a great way to make life
decisions. And so I do think this is
where taste comes in is that if we, you
know, I'd love to hear your definition
of taste, but in my definition here,
taste just means having a strong
barometer, having a strong compass of
what is good and what is not good and
not producing things that you know in
your heart are bad, right? Or like not
helping people or hurting people. You
make such a good point because I feel
like there's like a artistic definition
of taste which like I'm not much of an
artist like I don't really can't really
engage with and then there's just like a
pure like value generation, right? Like
almost in the kind of the core of the
economy like is what is what you're
doing positive some? It's weird because
like I think in a classic definition of
taste people are like well some people
have it and some people don't. I think
everyone has the ability to look at
something honestly and ask whether it's
>> well again the irony I'm you know you've
heard me say this before but anyone that
insists what good tra t taste they have
it's like definitionally that's how you
spot the people that don't have good
taste is that they talk about how great
they are all the time
>> well I think that's so funny because
like like when people are like oh taste
is like where the buttons are on the
screen or like how cool my dark mode is
like to
>> like you know like but to recognize
great taste in other people it's people
that have high standards
>> and that they really care. Yes.
>> About anything that they release,
they're proud of. Yes.
>> And they would stamp their name on it
and just be stand by their work and
the user gets value out of the work.
>> Yeah. Because there are a lot of people
if you stand by the work
>> but you don't care whether the user gets
value, that's art. Yeah. Which I think
is great. It's a perfect category of
things to do. But that's not building
businesses. Yeah. Like at the end of the
day, value has to be created to the
user. Interestingly enough, one would
argue we're in a slop war right now.
>> And maybe one would say like this is
what happens in any new platform kind of
zone, right? Like you got a a lot of
easy to slop out things and then things
kind of get sorted out.
>> Yeah.
>> How do you think about the slop war? Who
wins?
>> I would almost compare it to the
Facebook platform hop wars.
>> Yeah. where a lot of people were
competing with Zinga. Zinga was buying
people or compete with Farmville.
>> Yes.
>> And ultimately
no one won that was playing that game.
>> I mean, Facebook won.
>> That's true.
>> And so, yeah, the people selling tokens
are like, "Yeah, this is great.
>> Slop's great.
>> Everyone should use cloud code to make
like whatever they want."
>> But if you're the people consuming all
these tokens,
>> I think you want to stay out of a
symmetric battle for who can slop
harder. If there's a competitor and
they're spamming a lot and you're like,
"Well, our only solution is to spam
harder and you're just in an arms race
of who can create the most garbage to
make the graph go up."
>> Yeah.
>> I I think don't do it.
>> I think you have to find a way to stay
out of trying to produce the most
lowquality crap.
>> Yeah.
>> Whatever that is, whether it's features,
whether that's content, because again,
if you look at this to back test it,
usually the winners in any space stayed
out of these symmetric spam battles,
right, man? Well, it's funny because I
always like to think about, you know,
there have been phases where I've worked
in consumer and I've cared about my
topline user growth and then phases
where I've worked in consumer and I
cared about retention. There all kinds
of things you can do when you're only
looking at topline revenue growth or
topline user growth or topline dus.
There are all kinds of tricks. Why don't
we just send more push notifications
>> cuz that's what users really want.
>> Send more email. Let's let's send them
deceptive email. You know, there's a
problem with your account that'll make
our GAUs go up. We could go up with like
dark patterns all day long, right? Um
and and whenever I've had to work on
retention, it's like funny cuz it's like
you have to start with like, well, am I
helping user? Is it actually working?
Oh, if it is working, well, why do these
users not see that it's work? Like
everything comes back down to serving
someone. Whereas I feel like when I ever
I worked on the topline graph, I was
serving myself. The user was a side
story. The user was someone to be I
don't want to say exploited, but
certainly someone to be extracted from.
>> Whereas whenever I worked on retention,
it was like
>> it's hard to make these users happy. I
got to like I got to really do more
work. If you find yourself looking at
the graph that allows you to take more
from users than you give, I think that's
how you lose the slot war. If you find
yourself looking at the graphs that
other people don't want to look at,
that's how you win. Yep.
>> Yeah. I think the last thing I like to
talk about when it comes to slop and why
I would encourage kind of early stage
founders to be very careful is pre-slop
there was always there was already kind
of a high likelihood of people getting
to pivot help.
>> Yep.
>> What I worry about is like clog code and
slop might accelerate that already
pretty aggressive.
>> Well, because you can oneshot anything.
So basically, if you're if you're low
conviction
>> and you decide to pivot,
>> you can just
>> have the new thing
>> send it a Tech Crunch article and say to
clone it.
>> Yeah.
>> You like, oh, like clone this new
startup. And so it's even more tempting.
>> Yes.
>> To just randomly change your idea over
and over again and to build plausible
prototypes. Again, I'm I'm saying these
are like pretty good. Like it's good. I
like cloud code. And so
>> it's like we're giving
>> you're getting a really powerful weapon
like don't hurt yourself with it, right?
I think it's easier
>> to because you can crank out really good
prototypes so fast
>> to have lower conviction on what you
should be working on and to constantly
change your mind to seek the next shiny
thing.
>> Well, and we always talk about this, but
in pivot hell, the shiny thing is often
the thing you know the least about
>> because like you know why the things
that you experience or you use are hard
to build.
>> Yep.
>> So, it's kind of like it's so much
easier to go so much further astray from
things you know anything about. You only
have so much energy. Yep. Before you
wake up, look at your startup and you're
like, "This is not working. I got to
stop."
>> Think about it. You could you could
oneshot, hey, build a Salesforce clone.
I was been reading tweets about that.
Okay, here's your Salesforce clone.
>> Y now what? Try to get three startups to
use it. Oh, they don't like using it.
Oh, maybe I should build.
>> And wait, if it was so easy for you to
clone it, like why won't someone clone
you? And like like like basically you
can start poking at this and end up in a
very sad, low conviction place.
>> Yes. In conclusion, don't play in the
slop war.
Figure out how to focus on creating
value for users and maybe be a little
bit less addicted to graphs that go up
but where no value is being created. I
love graphs going up. Me too. Right?
Like graphs should go up, right? But
like graphs that go up where no value is
created come down. They they have a life
of a turkey.
Great chat. All right. Thanks, Michael.